this segment of our show is gold
sometimes maybe today i'm going to win
today chris because we are drafting the
way too early mvp candidates
it's my assumption since i haven't
received the trivia question to ask you
that you have a trivia question to ask
me you assume correctly my friend okay
so here we go
kyla murray is only the second
quarterback in nfl history with 300 plus
yards in his first two games okay
there's one other and he was drafted
within the last 10 years
who is he michael i don't know your
middle name florio
um you know you're trying to set me up
to say patrick mahomes i don't think
it's patrick mahomes i'll just throw a
dart here and say
that it is uh deshawn watson
sorry very close very close but sorry
the correct answer was a one cam newton
he did it remember that start he got off
to i mean that was amazing i could still
remember that going holy cow like what's
this guy going to do to the nfl it was
it looked pretty amazing
apparently i don't remember it i would
have gotten the answer right yeah well i
thought maybe now you'd remember since
we brought it up but i guess you don't
all right go ahead you you have the
first pick go ahead why don't you take
cam newton then uh
no uh he would be towards another the
opposite of this draft right now uh
patrick mahomes i'm still taking patrick
mahomes yep i mean he's still
uh the biggest difference maker in the
game right now just the way he's played
the last two weeks with that offense you
know the type of plays they ask ask him
to execute he's just phenomenal it's
hard to really argue against it because
yeah they got a good offense and they
got good players around him but he still
just has some plays every game where you
just go
holy crap is that special it's just
unbelievable uh in this week the second
quarter i mean i just never seen a team
who can flip the scoreboard flip field
position faster than the kansas city
chiefs
yeah and look the offense actually does
seem to be even better than it was last
year even without tyrek hill who was
injured in the first half of the win
over the jaguars in week one i think
mahomes the obvious candidate what he's
doing is just incredible and you know we
had talked in the off season whether or
not there would be any sort of a slump
because there's an opportunity to study
what he does but we both came to the
conclusion it doesn't matter because
patrick mahomes still makes things
happen and when things start to fall
apart that's when he's at his best and
you just can't stop him from doing the
things he wants to do it's like your x's
and o's thing with a tight end trying to
block a pass rusher ultimately you can
draw it up all you want but it's patrick
mahomes who is getting rid of that ball
so quickly from any body position any
arm angle that it's impossible to shut
this guy down all right yup
i'm going with dak prescott the
quarterback of america's team who has
been playing better than ever as he
chases that new contract almost so well
that the cowboys should consider not
paying him because while he chases the
contract he's actually better than he
was before he was chasing the contract
although it's only going to make it more
expensive when they finally do have to
pay him he has been phenomenal in both
games and i know they haven't played
great teams but that's okay he is
running that offense he's getting it
done i thought maybe there'd be a little
stumble against washington but they
pulled it off they ended up winning
going away and uh i think they're going
to win a lot of games this year and
prescott i said it last year in the
postseason the game against the rams
even though they lost he's becoming a
franchise quarterback before our eyes
and he has arrived as a franchise
quarterback a top ten guy a top seven
guy maybe before too long a top five
yeah he's he's wheeling and dealing it's
been amazing and and again yeah okay
it's not been the two greatest defenses
we've seen it doesn't matter i think
what you and i have seen the last two
weeks is a number of just big time
throws and plays and yeah there is you
know not everybody has been wide open
there's we just showed a clipping in the
rest of his game where he thread the
needle uh to omari cooper for a
touchdown i mean uh he he has really
come into his own and you said it right
at the end of last year into that rams
playoff game he showed us that he would
gone to another level that the when the
offense stalled he could take over a
game with his ability and that's what a
franchise quarterback is and that's why
you get in the conversation of being the
highest played player in football which
dak prescott is probably on the verge of
doing i would think he's going to be in
that conversation here within the next
few weeks okay good pick by you i got to
go with lamar jackson here i hate that
we just picked quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback but that's the
way this it's a quarterback award it is
that's how it works i know it's annoying
but lamar jackson's leading football and
quarterback rating right now and i don't
really care about the quarterback rating
altogether uh but either way lamar
jackson has been phenomenal through the
first two weeks i mean seven touchdowns
zero interceptions um you know
making
nfl quarterback big time throws you know
and again there was there were some big
ones in the dolphins yeah he was wide
open i get it you know okay but we
didn't take any credit away from tom
brady for carving up the dolphins this
past week so we can't take any credit
away from lamar jackson and
last week against the cardinals missed a
few throws but still was phenomenal and
then ran for 120 yards on top of it mike
uh lamar jackson has got off to a
phenomenal start to the 2019 season
and and there is a confidence in him a
swagger yeah there was a play against
the cardinals where he was running to
the left and he did a little bit of a
high step and it seemed like every time
i looked up at the screen of the ten
games that were going on in the early
window on sunday lamar jackson was
completing a pass i mean
this week was more of a complete running
and passing performance because
unlike the dolphins the cardinals
actually were defending the pass from
time to time but i think lamar jackson
is special he would have been my second
pick uh if if uh i hadn't uh gotten the
trivia question wrong so good pick by
you thank you look the the the even
though we're only two weeks in this is
why i wanted to do this right even
though we're only two weeks in it's
obvious where the cream has risen to the
top and it's going to stay there barring
injury these guys i think are going to
be in the conversation all year long and
i am going to go now
with
russell wilson and i should have i had a
tweet the other day where i mentioned
the way too early mvp candidates i
mentioned lamar jackson i mentioned
patrick holmes i mentioned dak prescott
i didn't mention russell wilson and i
should have he's been phenomenal nfc
offensive player of the week for week
two he's got almost 500 passing yards
averaging nine yards per attempt 134.5
passer rating five touchdowns no picks
and uh he's earning that 35 million a
year contract and people still don't
want to acknowledge i don't get it
why do people not want to acknowledge
that russell wilson is one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl is it because
they just assume he's a running
quarterback on a running team with a
great defense i don't understand it yeah
i think that's part of it a little bit i
think some people just think russell
wilson's a dork okay for lack of a
better phrase so they just don't want to
like him i do think there's a sentiment
out there i mean even here in the nbc
office i hear it all the time you know i
don't know that it's a dork i think
there's that there there's a certain
amount of his persona that's contrived
when he was seven years old and would do
mock press conferences that and and
there was an article in sports
illustrated a couple years ago how about
how it's all very manicured and it's not
really the guy i don't care about any of
that i know he's one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl that's right
that's all i'm saying but i think that's
part of the reason he doesn't get the
attention is because of the things
you're spot on i think that's what it is
but yeah we're not here to judge them
off the field we go with what we see on
sunday and we see a damn baller every
week and i just don't understand it
either i don't because you know they're
they're they're an offense that puts
tremendous pressure on him i mean they
really do i don't watch their offense
when i turn on film and go oh wow
there's people wide open and whoa i've
never seen these type of plays before
this is unbelievable i mean more times
than not it's just like hey you guy run
straight and russell will dance around
and he'll put it on the money and we'll
just move the ball that way and that's
it's like that's amazing he's a
franchise quarterback he's amazing he's
already getting into the conversation as
one of the greatest we've ever seen i
mean he really is i i think he's he's
he's he's joining that convo a little
bit okay
i'm gonna give it one i'm taking a
little love from the quarterback here
for my first one all right oh boy
yeah we saw him play monday night i'm
going with miles
gonna be yeah i know what you're doing i
got to go not going to win mvp he's not
going to even be close though there's
too many great quarterbacks probably the
only way a defensive player wins it is
in a year where there isn't a great
offensive performance probably or maybe
if he breaks the sack record that could
be one thing that could get him in that
conversation and right now miles
garrett's got five sacks in two weeks
probably could have like six or seven
really too uh but either way he is a guy
that we all knew was a freak of nature
physically um and he has joined the
class of you know khalil mack aaron
donald fletcher cox chris jones
some of the best defensive players von
miller in the league he's in that convo
and miles garrett has shown in the first
two weeks he can take over moments of a
football game and you know he stays at
this pace i think he can challenge you
know 22 and a half sacks and then and
get at michael strahan a little bit
i still don't think that makes him the
mvp michael strahan didn't win the mvp
award the year that he no i mean
cleveland will have to stay relevant too
yes cleveland will have to be in the
playoffs for that to happen you're right
even if he does it there's not going to
get it unless they're good too
i i i still think it's a quarterback
award especially this year with so many
great quarterbacks and i'm surprised
after you self-scouted yourself as
related to where you placed tom brady on
your quarterback rankings i'm surprised
you didn't take tom brady thank you for
allowing tom brady to remain on the
board because really i i sandbagged you
a little bit
um because i i i probably would have
taken him with my first round pick but i
had a feeling you wouldn't take him look
if they keep playing the way they're
playing and they indeed go 14-2 15-1
16-0 he'll be the mvp of the league
you know unless the chiefs are just one
or two games behind and patrick mahomes
sets a touchdown record or or a yardage
record it's gonna be tom brady and uh i
i think that right now even though
mahomes has been the better quarterback
and you could argue lamar jackson and
dak prescott have done more
i think if they cast the votes right now
uh well not right now but if it
continues the way it has from a team
performance standpoint it will be brady
when it's all said and done i mean i
don't disagree with you i mean yeah i i
certainly had brady here down and
written down i mean yes he's it's hard
to argue with any of those points and
he's been phenomenal i mean he really
has tom brady's special i know everybody
thinks i'm a brady hater because i said
he's the third greatest quarterback of
all time holy cow i'm such a heart and
you say he cheated well you say he
cheated yeah well he did i mean we know
that okay but either way no we don't
know awesome he's freaking awesome okay
i mean he really is and his arm is still
the story that's what's amazing mike i
mean his arm never got credit when he
was in his prime for how special it was
uh because he can do it so effortlessly
and i think now at 42 with everybody
starting to see the degree of difficulty
it throws he's still making with these i
think his arm's actually getting a
little more credit now but uh i'm just
amazed by it i mean he still he's just
got a phenomenal fastball touch he's got
it all and of course the team around him
is phenomenal too and they got a great
offensive system and you're right they
keep going this way i mean it doesn't
look like the patriots are ever going to
lose ever again they're going to win the
next two super bowls and he's gonna win
two more mvps and two more super bowl
mvps
and every super bowl they've won
since they started on this second phase
of their super bowl championship run has
come after the deflategate controversy
and uh the the evidence was inconclusive
at best as to whether or not there was
any actual chicanery happening with the
footballs and i know you disagree with
me but i i get the last one yeah i know
you did patrick mahomes lamar jackson
and miles garrett for you dak press got
russell wilson tom brady for me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports